you were the vp of twitter
obviously donald trump has just been
booted off twitter permanently what do
you think about that
there's a 70 year long study out of yale
university looking at what
the the secret of longevity and
happiness is and the secret of longevity
and happiness
is
work the thing we spend the majority of
our lives doing
today's guest is an expert on exactly
that
how can you be an expert on work bruce
daisley spent the last
five to ten years studying what makes
work
joyous what makes it miserable how we
get burnt out
and what matters the most when it comes
to work he's been named one of the most
influential londoners in the uk has been
named as one of the most influential
britons
in the united kingdom bruce daisley's
book the joy of work became the best
selling business hardback book in 2019
he has his own podcast so he's one hell
of a talker as well
and as the world has transitioned over
the last 10 months to this zoom-centric
remote working lifestyle
i think now is a great time to ask
ourselves the question
what makes work enjoyable how can we get
the most out of work how do we avoid
burnout
and how do we maximize our motivation
bruce has the answers
so without further ado my name is
stephen butler and this is the director
ceo
i hope nobody's listening but if you are
then please keep this to yourself
bruce you were you wrote a i feel like
that's an understatement you wrote a
smash hit book about
work called the joy of work and i've
seen this book absolutely everywhere
it's been an absolute phenomenon
so you know considering the fact that
the world has fundamentally shifted over
the last
nine ten months because of this pandemic
and the way we work has changed so much
i wanted to get your view of this remote
working
zoom um sort of working culture that has
now
been forced upon us just before i let
you answer i'm gonna give a little
sentence around around my take on it
i hate it um and
when when in march when we were forced
out as a ceo for business to tell my
employees that we're gonna be working
from home
and we have this amazing office which
gives us all this community um
i know that about 50 of my workforce
liked the idea
but i 100 hate it for a number of
reasons what's your take
so i think at the outset i shared some
of your reservations
brony brown talks about this thing which
is collective effervescence
and it's a it's a good way she's she's
coined to turn for something you see
quite a lot in social science
that even the introverts amongst us
actually quite like being around people
in
in some scenarios and we get
far more of our energy from the tribe
were in and the people were surrounded
with
then would probably admit and so when it
first happened
look the defining thing about work for
me is laughing every day
i if i laugh every day and i you know in
the organizations i've been in
they've been at times incredibly
stressful we've had
you know at times when i was at twitter
there was just for
good reason there was like big headlines
demanding stressful scenarios
but either the sort of the dark humor
that you find in those moments
or the moments of levity that you can
just get if you're around people that
you trust
soldiers talk about this or firefighters
talk about this you know you can find
human
and i used to love that so the idea of
shifting to a world where
somehow we're plugging into the matrix
and we were losing
that camaraderie that kinship that we
get
from being around other people i wasn't
necessarily the
the biggest advocate of it i think
what's clear though
is that we've fundamentally moved into a
different world and some of those
preconceptions that we might have had
might have been partly ill-judged so so
so working through those things that
the number one thing we know uh 91 of
people say they want to continue working
in some capacity
when you look at the numbers of that
people say broadly say they want to work
at home
three or four days a week so there's
some firms saying
we're going to let people work one day a
week or two days a week at home
people workers want to work more than
that so
there's going to be some degree of of
balance and we're going to achieve an
equilibrium
so that's the demand side of it and in
fact when you look at all age groups
young or old there is a slight
difference so
younger workers have said that they were
they're happy at home but they they it's
close to how happy they were in the
office
and we can partly understand that a lot
of young workers don't have
home offices they don't have nice desks
they're
sitting on their bed or they're sitting
on the table that
sits at the end of their bed so they're
working in slightly different scenarios
but even they report they're more
productive and happier than
than that they were in a big open plan
office so
that's the first thing older workers are
significantly happier
if you've got a bit of space it seems to
correlate with you feeling really happy
so broadly all of the evidence suggests
actually
the experience of it has been at least
unbalanced positive so then you look at
the
the other side and i guess it's firms
and it's really growing evidence that
firms are recognizing that
something has fundamentally changed
bloomberg did something interesting the
business people
they did an analysis of all the earnings
calls so all these transcripts of like
big bosses reporting to shareholders
what they think is going to happen and
bloomberg say that
already about one in eight firms are
talking about making their
offices smaller the ft did something
where they said about half of british
firms
are already talking about their offices
being smaller so
whether it's that demand side or whether
it's that supply side almost certainly
we're going into something that's going
to
look and feel a bit different to what we
were used to before
if you had to guess um i i completely
resonate with that i think
even for our organization we realized
how much money i'll be honest how much
money we could save
by not having an office because it's not
just the rent it's the
the cleaning the electricity it's the
food in the cupboards
you know the maintenance of a what was a
20 000 square foot office in manchester
uh and you you stripped back those costs
and you know it was that you were forced
to realize that
it is possible for there to be another
way and i think at first we were
we were skeptical that our business
could run in
completely remotely then we realized it
could and then we moved into phase three
which was like
okay but what have we lost now and it
was it was it was definitely a phase
three thing because in phase two we're
like oh everything's fine
in phase three we're like now we've got
a problem because we've lost the
uh the sense of community that our
company was giving to our employees and
for a company like ours
community was a huge part of our our
value-add you know we are the sterile
stereotypical like millennial office
with like the slides and the ballpark
and the freedom
and um and a real sense of strong
community where pretty much everyone
lives together
and so in phase three of this sort of
this sort of mental journey
what we saw and i actually resigned just
after in about
september time what we saw was a bit of
an exodus of our employees because now
they're sad at home they're looking at
their to-do lists
and that they're now thinking the
remuneration or the value i'm getting
from this job
is this amount of money and i'm doing
these set of tasks so now i think i can
get more
money down the street at that place that
has no working culture
whilst i'm still going to be sad at home
and it will be a similar set of tasks
and it was it was astonishing it was
astonishing how many people
um are being completely honest because i
have no reason not to be honest we
almost never lost
good people the month just before and
after i left
we we lost our the largest number of
employees
we've ever lost by a fault factor of 10.
yeah
and it's fascinating so let's look into
that because you're exactly
you spot on these the big themes that
are emerging now firstly
how can you make people feel like the
part of something when
the old way they felt part of something
was the energy they had when they're
around people right you know
there is some buzz and and it's not an
exaggeration i've chatted to
some of the world's leading experts and
they say good workplaces do have a buzz
to them they have
almost like this tangible energy um and
i think
that's one of the challenges we've got
now if you've got a situation where
people on video calls back to back
and you know it might be not with the
big boss it might be with clients
they're dealing with or it might be
with customers they've got to keep happy
but if there aren't back-to-back
meetings with those people
then they can just feel well look that's
going to be exactly the same wherever i
go we're not going to have
the same energy and there's far more
evidence that
when people feel part of something
bigger than themselves
it's transformational so i've been i'm
writing something about resilience at
the moment a book about resilience
and what you discover is that actually
what you hear about resilience is that
people
tell you all these myths about
resilience that it's this individual
strength or it's this
it's this trait that we can do develop
and what you discover about resilience
is it's normally a collective thing it's
because you
feel part of a resilient community you
feel like you've got
the strength of others to draw upon you
feel like you can
tap into something one person in some of
the research i was reading
said you can't be a resilient on your
own and there's so much truth in that
now what does that mean for the way
we're working right now well if you've
got someone in
a bed seat or a studio flat or a flat
chair
and they're sitting on their own all day
and they feel lonely
it's almost certain that those reserves
of resilience are being
tapped and you know there's one thing
that psychologists
talk about all the time it's this notion
of of affect
it's sort of it's a fancy way of saying
mood it's a psychologist a way of saying
mood
and what you discover about affect is
that
the the mood we're in is really
influential on a lot of the things on
our experience of life
and the uh creativity and our sense of
collaboration
so scientists talk about positive affect
and negative affect
and positive affect best way i can sort
of frame
uh positive affect it it suggests that
like the mood we're in
transforms some of the decisions we make
and the best way i can frame that is
that
when you're a kid growing up whether
your main carer is a grandparent or a
parent or a
a guardian but you knew from the age of
four or five
you knew that it was a good time to ask
for something and a bad time to ask for
something
you knew based on the mood that your
carer was in that there was a good time
to ask for something a bad time but
affect the mood we're in affects uh
decisions
well the situation we're all going
through right now is not positive affect
it's a negative affect
loads of people are feeling burnt out
average person during lockdown has been
working about an extra 45 minutes a day
that's on the back of the average
working day has gone up by two hours in
the last 10 years
so people are finding themselves in this
lonely unaffiliated disconnected
sense of exhaustive burnout so it's no
wonder people are quitting their jobs
because they just don't feel like the
good version of them that they used to
feel like you know the contrast as well
so this idea of contrast where you can
remember how your job used to be
and if your job used to be a 10 and now
because it's because a central part of
what made it a 10 say the community or
the culture in the office or you know
that sense of camaraderie
or that sense that you know you were a
group of people working together towards
a goal now you're kind of
sat in your bedside on your own on the
end of your bed doing a to-do list um
if your company was a 10 because of that
culture and it's now dropped down to a
six
something in my mind makes me think that
those companies will actually hurt more
versus the companies that were like an
eight before and an hour a six
um and that's part of what i think with
with our company social chain because
culture was such
a big thing that people must be thinking
oh my god what the hell is this
um being sat alone and we try i think
you know i can't speak to the company
now because i'm no longer there but
i know there was ample efforts with all
as with all companies to do these like
zoom bingo things and that lasted a
month before everyone got
sick to death of that but you mentioned
the word burn out there
uh a very popular phrase a topic of
much mystique as well i think um i saw
your ted talk about the topic of burnout
and i saw your
your thoughts there i guess my my
question is what causes burnout
in your view yeah there was a really
interesting there was a
a really interesting book that just came
out last year and it was based on
a a successful article that had sort of
blown up on
buzzfeed by a woman called an helen
peterson and she talked about
she the premise of her article really
good article worth searching for
is the the millennials of the burnout
generation you remember that one i think
maybe you showed it right there's all
these matchy
matches and what she said is she said
and she'd encountered it as a journalist
she's thinking
i'm feeling something i wonder if i
could capture it and she was thinking
is there such thing as errand paralysis
so what
she means by that is that she was
getting to the end of like these
productive working days
and then she would get back to her flat
and she would she would open a bill
or she had she had something she needed
to do and she just
didn't have the energy this high
performing
really successful person didn't have the
energy to get those things done
and so she was thinking in her head is
this some sort of weird
um this sort of duality that you can be
really accomplished
at one set of things but you can't
others she started looking into it and
she realized
it's not that you're avoiding one thing
you're just exhausted
and her lesson was that any time we
teach
we treat our energy as infinite that's
when burn out comes
and it we so often do it we we treat the
idea that we can work
all the time and the best examples i can
give you are the ones where
we actually check in on ourselves so i i
used to find myself
day job working at twitter worked on
twitter for eight years i used to
uh when i was especially guilty of this
i used to have back-to-back meetings on
monday
what's the consequence of back-to-back
meetings your inbox is
is exploding it's it's absolutely
overloaded
and so i used to get home on a monday
night get myself a cup of tea
deal with all my domestic
responsibilities and i would sit there
and work and do emails for about
four hours and just try and catch up
with what i was doing
and i quite often i would check myself
and about nine o'clock
i'd be spending as much time changing
the music as i would doing emails
or one long email that's like a
two-pager who sends these emails these
criminals sending long emails but i'd
find myself reading this
you know that feeling where you read it
i'll just read that again
and then read it again and what you
discovered there's this science for this
it's called ego depletion
and the people who look into this say
that our brains are sort of
far more finite far more limited than we
might imagine our brains are far closer
if you want a metaphor for it our brains
are far closer to the batteries on our
phone
than the infinite broadband that we we
normally deal with
so your brain's sort of got a certain
amount of charge in it and when you use
it
and so the way you'll you'll witness
this is maybe you walk into
a situation and someone asks you a
question at the end of a long day or
whatever
and you're like hang on can you just
just give me a minute just give me a
minute or someone asks you something
really complicated just as you're about
to oh
okay hang on can we just give and
effectively our brains are sort of far
more finite
once you recognize that you start
thinking okay i wonder if that
should influence the way i think about
doing my job and
and of course burnout is one of the
things where we don't
treat our energy as finite it is
it is uh finite but we don't treat it
like that and the end result is then
we just feel like we're running on empty
we're running on vapors
and so when you look into it the world
health organization
uh recognize burnout as a real
phenomenon
and they say that burnout is is all
about
when our energy feels spent when we feel
emotionally exhausted
they talk about this other thing called
depersonalization where
when you're really burnt out you don't
necessarily
construe other people as full and
empathetic individuals but sometimes
you're a bit sort of
dismissive of other people or you're a
bit reductive of their motives or
you start seeing people around you as an
annoyance so in the old days if you ever
found that the person you sat next to
their chewing or their tapping was
driving you crazy that can be a little
bit of an exam
example of deep personalization so it's
a real phenomenon
it's uh i think to my mind it makes you
rethink
the way you work so if you knew okay the
most i can do every day
is eight productive hours of work and
you can
you know there are evidence to suggest
you can do more than that but if you
started treating it like that
and said maybe actually if i'm honest
it's not a
really high intensity productive hours
but maybe it's five or six really good
hours
and then you know other stuff is dealing
with email or dealing with
with phone calls it i suspect it would
change the way you made decisions
and you see evidence of this barack
obama used to have someone who followed
him round
who uh barack obama never chose his
lunch in eight years
because this person just made all his
decisions for him and
you see albert einstein said something
similar einstein used to wear that same
outfit every day
and uh it was because he knew when he
got to his lab when he got to
the the place he was making uh decisions
he knew that if he went there and he
hadn't
cluttered his brain with all these
little micro decisions
he was he just felt a bit more
imaginative inventive creative
so we see evidence of it in other
people's behavior but normally when it
comes to us we don't treat
our brains like that we don't treat it
like something we need to protect
our energy to protect we we tend to
treat our energy as infinite but that's
why burnout comes just
does the type of work you know you talk
there about eight hours or five hours or
whatever it might be
does the type of work you're doing and
the amount of intrinsic
motivation you have or joy you get from
it impact your
likelihood of being burnt out yeah
because like because that's what i
that's what i suspected in my life
because
the people that i've seen that get burnt
out and this is all anecdotal and
there's no scientific evidence really to
support
these these assertions but people that
i've seen get burnt out the most
typically typically especially during
the lockdown
working alone often often freelance um
often doing a repetitive task
usually doing things that aren't that
enjoyable and i had a friend actually
come here and sit on the sofa which i've
talked about i think in the last few
podcasts
and he basically told me that he was
feeling a bit burnt out um and
uh he was struggling to get out of bed
and go and do the
go and do his work in the morning he's a
he's a freelance freelancer
working on his own in his house he used
to work within teams during pre
pandemic and i i was saying to him like
think about the things that make your
work enjoyable and what other you know
what are the things about work that are
intrinsically and
motivating to you all those things have
gone right now so now you're just left
with
waking up alone sitting in front of a
computer
and maybe because your intrinsic
motivations or the intrinsic joy
of your work has been stripped maybe
you're now um
encountering burnout i think that
resonates with me as well to some degree
like
if i've ever got close to feeling
unmotivated or quote unquote
burnt out it was when i was doing things
alone pre-social chain
on my own just for money well there's a
couple of things there
so two things so like this i think is
all related to resilience
so there's two things there the first
thing is that the evidence we have
is that when we feel an absence of
control we do
we generally feel more burnt out so
let's think of examples and the research
on this some of the best research on
this is about nurses
so very timely for the moment we're in
right now when nurses
choose to work extra hours or you might
have known friends when you were doing
jobs before your career where you know i
used to work in fast food and some of
those dudes used to work 14 hour shifts
and you're like wow where did they get
the energy but they were electing to do
it
and the evidence we have is that when
people choose to do those things
it often impacts them less they they
feel like they've got control over it
so you know i these guys who used to
work with burger king king
at me with me and they were doing 100
hour weeks but because they were
choosing to do it because it was really
important for them to afford a car to do
things
they were what you discover is that when
you're electing to do it does
seem to give you some degree of
protection so control is a really
important part the more control
we feel over our lives so why might you
now be feeling burnt out because imagine
if your company has you on
40 hours of zoom calls a week or your
inbox is always
full or you've got a difficult person
you have to deal with a
client relationship who's phoning you
all the time you might be feeling the
absence of control
or your your friend who's the the
freelancer might be feeling like i'm
just
i'm not in control of things but there's
a couple of other really important parts
and they're about our identity and about
the the sense of community
and you get really good evidence of how
when we feel part of something bigger
than us and
feeling that connection being around
people is a really important part of
that
it tends to enrich us it tends to to
protect us and you see really good
evidence of this you see when people go
to hospital
if they have like a heart operation or
they have something serious when they
come out of hospital
the people who reported that they were
part of groups before
their chance of survival their chance of
avoiding depression
is massively higher than those who
live in isolation and look that's the
experiment we're going through right now
that
you might have wonderful friends that
are at the end of a zoom line or a
messenger link or a whatsapp
but if you're not around them and to
some extent some of the energy we get
from them is dissipating
and i think that's the challenge that a
lot of us are in right now
it's just a very lonely existence we've
got now all of the things that we found
nourishing enriching life-affirming a
lot of them have been taken away from us
now the challenge go on i was just gonna
say i was gonna say um
actually there's a lady that sat in your
in your chair yesterday
anna hemmings and she's an 11 time or
11 time world gold medal world champion
amazing olympian etc etc and she was
speaking to the fact that at one point
in her career
when she's when she she was training in
london to be a kayaker so she's like an
eleven-time world champion kayaker
right and then at one point in her
career they decided that they wanted her
to go to the olympics so she had to
learn sprint kayaking right
the coach was in florida so they took
her away from her team
in london and she had to basically train
on her own
via using an email that her her coach in
florida was selling her
and after doing that for a couple of
months she got chronic fatigue syndrome
wow
so she was out for two years she said
she couldn't lift her hands
and shampoo her and the thing that
brought her back was the realization
that taking away
her from her team as someone who was a
bit of an extrovert and got her energy
from people
had um set off a bunch of alarm bells in
her body
so the the reason that she managed to
recover and come back and
win more world titles after two years of
literally having this chronic fatigue
syndrome
was by realizing that and putting her
back with her teams
and changing her training which is wow
what a metaphor for what we're going
through
right and it shows how the mind is so
intrinsically connected to the body yeah
people don't think that
loneliness or removing you from your
tribe
can disable your body yeah or your
energy but although there's remarkable
amounts of evidence on that so there's a
woman in the u.s called
julianne holt lunchtime who's done like
a colossal survey
and she appropriates she says loneliness
is the equivalent of smoking 15
cigarettes a day
and so you know it has this big impact
on us and loneliness is
as bigger than obesity in terms of the
health impact it has on you
and that's what we're going through
right now and for all of these things
that we've tried to sort of create these
artificial intel alternatives
zoom quizzes and all manner and things
like that they just don't
have the same connection of
feeling surrounded with someone there's
some evidence as soon as you start
looking into these things it's
extraordinary
what an impact people have on each other
so these one
piece of evidence i went up to to oxford
to meet the woman who did this
research and she took groups of rowers
similar to
to the kayaker took groups of roads
first and there are oxford university
roads you've seen them the colossal
the monsters and she she put the first
group individually on rowing machines
second group she said okay i want you to
be on a
a made-up boat you know you're going to
sit on your rowing machines but you've
got to be in stroke with each other
and she wanted to see firstly what was
the different experience
what she noticed was that the firstly
they did about the same
exercise it wasn't like someone worked
harder than others but she measured the
endorphin levels
you do that by uh you put these arm
cuffs on people you sort of
you subject them to pain and then you
see how much pain they can take and
the endorphin levels of the people who'd
rode together was twice as high
as the people who'd rode alone and you
know you see this with choirs
people who sing inquired you know you
can grab strangers off the street
get them to sing some abba songs
together and you say to them at the end
of it
how do you feel they say i feel utterly
elated now that's not because singing
our songs on its own does it it's
because when you feel some connection
with other people
even strangers it seems to be
transformational it seems to sort of
elevate our mood and all of that has
been stripped from us
so you know if you've got i guess you
can try to do some approximations of it
but all of that has been stripped from
us and i think that's why
it's it's inevitable that we are feeling
flat energy-less we it doesn't feel the
same right now how do we fix that though
and this is i think it's going back to
the start of the conversation
why i hate it i hate the lack of
connection i hate the lack of community
i think are you an extrovert would you
say
oh god i really don't know i think on
one hand i'm a massive introvert yeah
i i i'm people know me i don't like to
do i don't like small talk i like to sit
alone for weeks on end
i like i went off to the jungle for four
weeks in september alone
went off to the costa rican jungle alone
so i like that although i
have this kind of like you know public
speaking and social media brand
so i actually don't know although a lot
of introverts like that ability to
switch on the public speaking side and
but i think actually the more you look
into the introvert extrovert thing it's
sort of
a compartmentalization that doesn't
necess the vast majority of people sit
somewhere and sure
exactly i'm the same as you um no but
these
uh i i think look the point you raise is
there's no easy substitute
but there is some evidence i saw an
amazing piece of research
and it looked at couples who lived
distance relationships
so you know in the uk distance
relationship means you're half an hour
an hour's drive from someone
in the us it means you're like a three
hour flight so they did a piece of
research 40
000 couples living distant relationships
and they wanted to know so these were
unmarried so they wanted to know the
ones who made it through a year what
what was the thing that made it through
a year and this was research was done
three or four years ago so it's not from
a different era of technology
but the ones who stayed with each other
for the long term
phoned each other every day and you know
when they
they were asked what you talked about
they said oh we just talked about
trivial things
so i think so many of us have got into
this frame of mind of thinking
well i liked her a photo and i sent a
quick whatsapp saying what i sent
a voice note horrific use of technology
but they said
but you know we think somehow we've
serviced the relationship by doing these
things
and actually when you come down to it
and maybe future generations will be
different
but it's it's often quite analog it's
that sense of feeling
seen and appreciated so i suspect face
time might work the same way
but so many of us are sort of are
overwhelmed with these performative zoom
calls right now where he's sitting there
with
like a celebrity squares a blanky blank
uh
array of faces in front of you i know
and i wonder if it's that sense of being
seen and being heard
that probably connects and cuts through
a bit more
yeah i think so yeah i just think work
is just so much
more than the work right i think
especially in the world in
the world we live in at the moment where
we're getting lonelier as a society i
was looking at the stats when i was
writing my book about
you know the the when they ask americans
for example how many people
they can turn to at a time of crisis it
used to be three people a couple of
decades ago now they're like medium
answer is zero
yeah and um i think it was theresa may
that appointed a
head of loneliness where loneliness are
for the uk and i've seen the stats so i
think work is one of the few sort of
i don't know institutions where it still
binds us together
um and we're not between four white
walls tapping glass to order food and
alone speaking to our nan through a
piece of glass so it's a shame that that
that community that part of community's
gone but anyway moving on
creativity something you've talked about
at length and
um for me i've i've always believed that
i'm least creative in the office i've
always thought
i'm more creative in the gym and in the
shower than i am when i'm when i'm sat
in a boardroom with a bunch of people
and i know this is something you've
spoken about so i wanted to get your
take on where we're most creative what
kills and causes creativity
yeah i mean look firstly i would all i
ever feel in all of these situations is
that i feel like i'm a
a vessel that's passing on other
people's knowledge so i've found myself
being consumed with all these things and
interested in their learning so
look let me tell you um what i've i've
discovered that
neuroscience is really intriguing the
most compelling thing about neuroscience
is when you look into it
uh neuroscientists used to work on
experimenting on animals
you know i'm not i'm not keen on that i
was like i was
you know in a protest group about animal
experimentation when i was younger
um and they used to look at brain
injuries so that used to be the main way
that neuroscience worked
and it's only the last 20 years that
brain scans have had any degree of
sophistication
but what they've discovered in like the
time that they've had brain scanners
is some of the things that they presumed
about the way our brain works
aren't necessarily right so let me give
you one example but they used to put
people in these brand new brain scanners
and they would watch what their their
brains did they give them a puzzle they
give them a
rubik's cube their brains would light up
in these sort of different places
and then they'd notice what happened
when people stopped
playing on the puzzle and their brains
would light up in sort of
loads of places as well and so it was it
was baffling
what's going on right now they'd say to
these people they say oh right sorry i
was
a million miles away i was daydreaming
so okay
right that's interesting your brain's
lightened up when you're when you're not
thinking about something when you sort
of switched off
and so the way that neuroscientists
categorize this broadly they say
these three systems of cognition first
one is like
when you're doing that rubik's cube or
when you're typing an email
it's called the executive attention
network so it's the main thing you're
focusing on
and then you'll know while your
executive attention network is watching
netflix or
while you're writing an email you can
also be aware of like the room you're in
that's called the salience network and
the third one the third
so there's three of these systems the
third one is that one when you're
daydreaming the one where you're a
million miles away
the one when you're in the shower which
is called the default network
but what we discover is that people
generally report
having their best creative ideas not
when they're frowning into their laptop
screen
but when they're in these default mode
uh situations so you might have it in
the old days
if you're on a train somewhere or on a
plane somewhere loads of people
i've got a friend who says she has all
her best ideas
staring out the windows of planes yeah
and so you know
if that was you then this year has been
an uncreative year
but um my favorite example of it is a
really famous screenwriter
called aaron sawkin he's written the
west wing he wrote
there was a um there was a film he had
on netflix just before christmas called
the chicago seven he's written all these
big things
very famous for zingy dialogue so he
wrote the social network film things
like that sort of
you know um really sort of really what's
better than a
million a billion like he's written all
these zingy lines and he's
realized that uh he has all his best
ideas exactly like you in the shower
he said he had he told hollywood
reporter magazine he had a shower
installed in the corner of his office
and he has eight showers a day and he
was asked by them
he was asked by them hang on is this
like some weird
ocd thing he said not at all i find that
when i
you know so i'll be sitting there
thinking of something
trying to come up with an idea but it's
only when i disengage my brain
to something comes to me an idea comes
to me and so
what you described is exactly what a lot
of
these people whose job is to be creative
have recognized
and as soon as you know that you start
thinking
wow okay i need to think differently
about
being creative because creativity can
then be when i'm sitting at my desk i'm
sort of
taking all this inspiration in
stimulation
ideas but then it's about disengaging
going for a walk
going for a cycle ride going to to do a
workout
might be the moment where the idea hits
you and i don't think necessarily we
think about that enough
you know if you go back to this idea
that your brain is a bit like your phone
battery
then some of those moments that
effectively can recharge your battery
can be the moments where creativity hits
you and inspiration hits you
so i think sort of rethinking the way
that we
treat a productive week of work of you
know these blocks of work
but then moments where you know it might
be your
personal is you go for a walk every
lunch time
that can be far more creative and
productive than you might imagine
well how do we make our work
environments more conducive with
creativity then is there a way or do we
just resign to the fact that
that's not going to be the best place
for our creativity and if we're going to
reach our creative potential it's
probably going to be away from the
office
i think it's about recognizing there's a
yin yang there's a balance
of work and and imagination
so i i always loved the example of um
charles dickens
charles dickens obviously um like
incredibly productive i think he wrote
15 novels
200 short stories he edited a weekly
magazine about a mile from here
you know sort of incredibly productive
we didn't work afternoons
and so charles dickens would sit down at
his desk at eight in the morning
he'd write for about four or five hours
and then he'd go and walk and he'd walk
10
10 miles every afternoon and that was
like
him lost in his thoughts you know
striding through
east london probably sort of imagination
popping
when he sat down the next day he had
loads of ideas and i think
some of us have eliminated that
sort of the brain fermenting ideas we've
eliminated that a bit so
you know it might be that your way to do
this yourself is just
to make sure you just got some down time
or you've just got some time where
you know you put music on but you turn
podcasts off or you just
you try and get a bit more balance in
how you're
uh using your energy so let's conclude
this point about work
and creativity say that i today
made you the ceo of a company that had
100 employees
um and you could design from scratch the
the working environment how often people
worked and some of the sort of
key sort of principles and foundations
of that working environment what kind of
things would be important to you based
on all you know
so let's look into what happened in
lockdown the first part of lockdown most
people reported
that their engagement went up and why
did their engagement went up
their engagement went up because they
were solving problems like we'd never
worked like this before
everyone was you know the first moment
you're getting on a zoom call or a
google hangout or
you're getting on these things there's
like you know even though you're in this
crazy situation
there's a degree of excitement fight or
flight almost right and
and so what do we know about that we
know that people felt that they were
involved in firstly a bit of team
collaboration but secondly they were
helping solve problems
and so you know the whole organizations
computer sales
have gone through the roof whole
organizations that had no laptop
computers
so they had to arm their teams with kit
and so people
felt really engaged by the fact that
they back to what we talked about
earlier
had some control they had a a bit of
influence
so number one thing that we discover is
the more that people feel that they can
have an
impact in their job and it might be
something similar simple
they're they're just responsible for a
couple of things themselves
the more that they feel that they've got
some agency some control themselves
they feel motivated in their jobs when
do we feel unmotivated in our jobs
when our boss tells us what to do but we
don't get
any input into it we don't necessarily
think it's
the best thing to do we're doing
repetitive things that don't feel very
rewarding
so the best thing that any of us can do
think well how can i make
teams feel small and teams feel like
they've got a shared sense of
accomplishment and pride in what they're
doing so that's what i would be saying
what you discover is 100 is a really
nice size actually any time a
company goes over 100 what your
discovery is
you lose a bit of some of that
camaraderie
you better almost there's a few
organizations that do this
when you go over 100 split it into two
teams because your
that sort of cohesion you get works
really well when we
we've got a familiarity with each other
and what happens is when you go over
that you start losing it
and you think we want we want it to feel
like it used to feel
it's never going to feel like that
humans don't work like that so
far better to say you know we've got two
teams that love each other but we're
we're working on separate goals so
keeping things small
is really critical and there's lots of
evidence of
the smaller you can keep things you
almost get the economies of engagement
compared to the economies of scale that
when people feel they're part of
something that they're having an input
into
their engagement is higher they they
they work more effectively
so i would say that would be the
defining part making people feel like
they've got things that they're
responsible for
and generally all of those things
encourage
active engagement what you find when you
look into some of the stats
they're terrifying so and when you
globally there's
an organization gallop to this workforce
survey
opinion poll company and they they do
this workforce survey and they say that
globally
13 of people are engaged in their jobs
when they look into it what i mean by
that is that these there's almost as
many
people there's about 22 of people who
would
actively disengage their jobs so by
actively disengaged
they kind of hate their organization and
they want to bring the downfall of their
organization
so anytime you meet some someone on the
tuber in the street they're almost twice
as likely to want to destroy their
company
as make it succeed but then the vast
majority of everyone else over 50
percent of people
are just disengaged they're not actively
disengaged
they're just passively disengaged so
work for most of us
is something is something that sort of
feels arduous we don't necessarily enjoy
we don't necessarily
value the decisions and you'll know as
someone who's
run a company where culture was the
defining thing you'll know that when you
get it right
it can be this superpower where you know
you're on
high octane fuel compared to you know
the energy can feel low otherwise and so
just getting those things right
generally is far more about
people feeling a personal connection
with the people that are around
feeling like they're contributing
something these things play a really big
part
we talked a lot about the joy of work
obviously the i guess the antithesis of
the joy of work is the misery of work
and at some point when work
feels miserable um people are faced with
this quite
um this quite confounding question which
is
how do i know when to quit and we talk
that we know i think there's so much
written about
how to start and when to start and
starting being the thing but obviously
the thing that comes before starting
usually is knowing the right moment to
quit
people don't quit sometimes and they
spend many decades in a miserable job
and
you know then their fear of quitting
almost becomes stronger because they're
getting more comfortable and more
entrenched
so i wanted i've not seen you talk about
anything about quitting before but i
just wondered if you had a take on when
the right moment to quit a job was or
i know it's an incredibly personal
nuanced thing but people
i can i was thinking then i was thinking
what are some of the things people
really want to know right now one of
them i'm sure is like i hate my job
i don't have control my boss is an
[ __ ]
do i quit i'm gonna tell you a secret
for the past five years while building
social chain into a 700 person
global social media powerhouse i've been
using a service that i've never really
mentioned
some of you might know that service it's
called fiverr f-i-v-e-r-r
it's my little secret if i've ever had a
project where i've needed affordable
skilled freelancers to help me whether
it's building a social media application
that made my company three
million pounds or just a video i needed
editing or
help making a logo or making a website
i've used fiverr
now that my secret's out the bag here's
what i'm gonna do for you if there's a
freelance service you need or a project
you need help with a logo
a website a voice over a video you need
made anything at all
go to fiverr.com ceo i'll put the link
in the description
that's fiverr.com ceo
message me the service you want from the
website and every single week i'll
personally
send you the credit to your fiverr
account so that you can get that project
done
thank you to fiverr for the sponsorship
and for supporting entrepreneurs and
freelancers around the world
i'm looking forward to all of your
messages i've been working my way
through these
huel nutrition bars this week um as you
know i love the ready to drink cure
flavors but
you will have also got these salted
caramel bars
and i'm a big salted caramel nut which
i've been having and if you're if you're
someone that does like to chew
not just drink your food then i really
highly recommend the salted caramel
flavor there's also another flavor
called the raspberry white chocolate
flavor
which i've been very addicted to over
the last couple of weeks but again just
like huel it's nutritionally complete
you get all of your
your proteins you get essential fats you
get it's gluten-free as well
and you get 26 vitamins and minerals
from these bars
tastes amazing and i'm a big salted
caramel fan give it a go if you do
send me a screenshot on instagram or
twitter or linkedin and let me know what
you think
again as someone that skips meals this
is an absolute lifesaver
i was thinking what are some of the
things people really want to know right
now one of them i'm sure is like
i hate my job i don't have control my
boss is an [ __ ]
do i quit yeah look you know big
questions you probably could tell us
more than that
um yeah i think you know the uh the
critical thing about that is
is probably checking in with yourself
and asking you know do i feel any sense
of
reward by my from my job obviously it's
not a great time for anyone right now to
be
debating doing something that makes them
economically precarious
that so you don't necessarily want to
risk something that is going to
put you in a difficult situation but i
think you know evaluating our jobs
generally when you look into the
research when you say to people have you
had a good days
a good day at work it generally comes
down to whether people feel pride in
their organization
and whether they feel like they've made
meaningful progress in something they've
been working on
so meaningful progress actually can be
difficult right now if your job feels
like
you're the expert in emailing and
video calls you sometimes feel like
you've made no progress for weeks you
haven't done
anything for weeks and also if your
organization is struggling
this is a really interesting phenomenon
because some organizations pre-covered
were in
uh were growing so naturally when you're
an employee in those organizations
you're dragged up with it you're giving
promotions and pay rises and
there's the cash to fund that now
organizations are in decline or a lot of
them are hanging on
and so you're not getting a promotion
your pay's been frozen you might have be
on a pay cut
you might be furloughed and it feels
like suddenly you've gone into decline
in your career because the organization
you're in is
in decline um and i think that also
causes a lot of people to start to think
well
you know i might my whole life up until
this point has been about
progress and climbing the ladder why am
i going down the ladder yeah
i didn't do anything different or wrong
you know it's a really interesting
philosophical thing about that because
the whole idea of the career
at korea is the invention of the last 40
years you know
uh ancestors uh grandparents our
great-grandparents
never had the idea of a career where i
was going to be
accomplishing something and developing
and changing
you know the job you were going to be
doing next year was the job you were
doing last year well done
and the job that your kids were going to
do was going to be the job that you did
and the the this idea and it brings with
it a degree of insecurity
this idea that we will be on this
developmental path
is a construct look and it's a construct
that suits the
economic system we live in because it
makes us
all we strive to be accomplishing more
than we did last year and to be earning
more than we did last year
but it's a construct for the last few
years whether it's the origin of
happiness
i'm not 100 sure if i was going to put
two things alongside some of the things
that you've talked about
that sense of feeling part of something
feeling connected to other people
i think is a more robust route to
happiness than
feeling like i'm on a career trajectory
even though that can the the illusion of
that can be incredibly powerful
it's interesting because you know with
there's this thing called like gold
medal depression where like michael
phelps he
set these set these tarts one thing i
kind of investigated in my book is the
idea that
we think stability we think chaos we
think we live in chaos
and and in search of stability but the
moment we find stability i.e completed
goals
and um you know roof over our heads and
everything's normal we actually descend
into chaos
so in fact we're meant to keep this is a
philosophical idea i guess but
we're meant to keep our lives in forward
motion in that chaos because
when you look at people that have
achieved all their goals and they have
nothing left to accomplish
they so often fall into some kind of
depression and lack of purpose and
meaning
i think jordan peterson talks about it i
know benjamin said a lot about it that
you know much of um i was looking at the
stats around
life expectancy in the uk and the us and
over the last two years it's declined
for the first time ever
but and they say when they say why is
that they say because the opioid crisis
and say why is there an
opioid crisis and they say well because
there's a lack of meaning
and so i i began to realize that in my
own life
i think i'm meant to keep myself
my goals way out in front of me almost
unattainable um
and keep myself striving and i've even
seen it in my person which i've talked
about a little bit on this podcast the
days where
someone came along and said here's 50
million will buy a company or we're
going to go to the stock market you're
going to be a millionaire were the most
confusing days of my life
because i immediately didn't know what
my point was anymore
i wonder what there's something really
fascinating so there's a there's a study
of
olympic medalist a british study really
fascinating piece of work
it's called the great british medalist
study and um it was commissioned by the
british olympic association so they
wanted to know
what was the what was the creation of a
champion
and they did this fascinating thing they
did they gathered 20
what they called super elite athletes so
these are athletes you'll know them
all of them are household names they
don't name them in the study but it's
people like kelly holmes it's people
like
the big iconic names and uh these were
people that every time they went to
a championship they would win gold or
they would win
they would be right in contention then
they took a second group and they called
these elite athletes
super elite elite and these were people
who went to championships
but kinda didn't meddle or if they
meddled they meddled third
biggest difference between them these
ones had all received significant
childhood trauma the elite ones the
super early best ones had achieved
significant childhood trauma let's start
counting the cases
so kelly holmes she was bullied at
school she was
the only child of mixed race
ethnicity in her village she said she
experienced continual racism
tom daley his father died when he was
training
yeah um you know you look at countless
examples of these things the
andy murray was you know greatest
british tennis player maybe
greatest british sports person he was at
the dumb lane shooting the only mass
shooting
in british history so all of these
people have experienced significant
childhood trauma
and what happens is they tend to direct
their energy
based on what we know they direct like
they're fortunate
there was a coincidence that they were
gifted supreme talent
and what you discover is childhood
trauma normally correlates with
addiction
so if you know if it correlates with
anything it correlates with
obsessive behavior but both of them have
something in common
you're trying to fill that void and so
these people are fortunate that they've
been gifted with this
super elite talent that they can fill
the void with striving for something
and the people who ends up at addicts
with the same challenge don't but
they're still striving to fill that void
and so there is something in you know
it's it's almost inevitable that these
people who are striving for the elite
uh accomplishment hoping to fill this
this hole that sits inside them of
course when they get there they realize
it was all an illusion it's like a
mirage in the desert but you know there
is something in what you say
i mean i've got i just i mean completely
like i think
when i i sit here and speak to people
that are tremendously successful
and the one thing that i've seen in
common with all of them actually think i
said it to joe wicks when he was sat
here
two weeks ago was they all seemed to
have some real severe childhood trauma
that no one else has experienced
and even in my i said to joe i said you
know my i've got a friend who's a
billionaire
he's not happy but he has had this deep
obsession since he was a kid because of
some things that happened with his
father and his father making him feel
that he just wasn't enough or he wasn't
adequate enough
which has made him obsessive about
success to the point where it's
unhealthy
um and he's got there now he's a
billionaire but he's not happy at all
he's he's you know he's tremendously
unfulfilled the same with eddie han i
went and eddie holmes on this podcast a
couple of weeks ago as well
and he he is the most relentlessly
obsessed person i've met
um just non-stop eat to the point where
he'll say to his kids like
he'll he'll tell his wife and kids that
they are second priority to his box to
being a boxing promoter
you ask him where that's come from he
said you know my dad my dad always made
me feel like i wasn't enough
it's really interesting though because
it depends i'm intrigued then
how these people pay it forward because
andre agassi
supreme tennis player great tennis
player married to the greatest the
up there equal greatest tennis players
for all time uh he's married steffi graf
and um and he says that his dad bullied
him constantly
like his dad was never happy he's the
only place his dad who was
a persian iranian cab driver could
afford to own a tennis court was in las
vegas
so they moved to las vegas and his dad
bullied him into becoming a tennis
player
and andre agassi fantastic autobiography
wrote about how much he hates tennis
hates it with every single bit every
fiber in his body
and he says i will never do to my kids
what my dad did to me
and so it's like this really interesting
origin of
success is the thing that propels you
this driving force that propels these
people
who just keep going relentlessly is it
something missing rather than something
extra and i think that's the interesting
conundrum
i don't think it's predictable and this
is the thing because i think you think
okay well if someone has trauma
they're going to become successful or
they're going to become an addict
or if someone has a
upbringing that lacked empathy from
their parents then they'll become an
[ __ ] or a serial killer
but in the case of joe wicks he was he
talked about how he had you know he
looked at
the doors in his house and they all had
fist holes in them his dad was an
addict his mom had these problems and
and he is the single most empathetic
person i've ever met
you know when they announce the third
lockdown he does a livestream crying his
eyes up because not because of him he's
fine he's saying i can i'm feeling the
pain
of people losing their jobs right now
and you think well if your dad was
you know you grew up in a home full of
domestic abuse right and violence
how can you become the most empathetic
person that i've ever encountered
genuinely genuinely empathetic this guy
like i've never seen
you know um i you know because everyone
says about you know pee with joe
and they all like send him the memes
every time there's a lock down of him
like putting his shoes back on or
whatever but the guy
gets really down really really really
down
because he knows that other people are
hurting never seen anything like it
however here's my question so we talked
about childhoods um
making people very interesting there's
one guy in particular who is
notoriously had a very um interesting
childhood which made him a certain way
donald trump and his father um
you know the story of donald trump and
his father being you know um
you were the vp of e-m-e-a
of twitter um obviously donald trump has
just been booted off twitter permanently
what do you think about that but also i
wanted to ask you where if you were jack
dorsey in that at that time would you
have made the same decision
number one it's so incredibly hard and i
think
the i mean i always felt lucky i worked
four years at youtube
before twitter and the time that i
worked at youtube
there was a lot of um mass shootings and
there's always mass shootings in the u.s
but there's a lot of mass shootings and
the phenomenon at the time was that a
lot of the mass shootings
it was being discovered that the people
had youtube channels
and so i remember sitting in a meeting
with lawyers in the
san bruno headquarters of youtube
watching them
debate what the the right moral thing
to do was in these fascinating to watch
things that were being invented
challenges that no one had conceived of
five years before now you've got these
things and so you're watching all these
things going on
and um and so you know when twitter was
invented when twitter was invented it
was a way
15 years ago it was a way to text all of
your mates at once
and so there was a short code and it was
a way it was
it took like your msn messenger status
and it sent it to text messages that was
the idea before everyone had internet
connection on their phone
so that it feels like a different
lifetime now
but just an illustration to be 15 years
on from that
debating whether you d platform the most
powerful most well-known is he the most
famous person in the world maybe the
most famous person in the world to
de-platform that person
is such a journey to be on and i know
the people
i mean i know jack i know uh the the
other person who made the decision
and i know that they don't make any of
those decisions lightly you know it's
like
it's really uh weighs on them but to my
mind
it was a singular situation where
firstly i saw some people on social
media saying
um saying that this was an illustration
that the employees of tech firms were
woke
and it's just really interesting
equivalents because six people died
in that event and if you watch back all
the footage
of what led to it then it
it doesn't take a huge leap of logic to
say
i can see why that created that so six
people died and i think
it was at the end of a long period where
increasing numbers
of the tweets by the president and the
people associated
were being labeled with this isn't true
and you you do reach a point where a lot
of critics were saying
where does your responsibility kick in
here do you have no responsibility for
what your platform is being used for i
think knowing the people concerned
that that was the last thing they wanted
to be to be in the position where
they were making a decision angela
merkel has come out saying
she's she feels uncomfortable with it
and i can definitely imagine that
everyone in twitter
felt uncomfortable with it it was one of
those difficult things everywhere you
went for the whole
trump presidency people would say um
what are you doing why are you not
taking this down and of course you know
the first thing you've got to say is
irrespective of anyone's opinion and
that's the only way you can look at this
that this is an elected leader of a
country
and so you know irrespective of anything
else
for a private company to be saying that
we
we take an opinion which transcends
uh the election result is a really
uncomfortable one
so i know that it would have been a
really careful decision i think a really
deliberate decision
jack's been on podcasts and any places
uh i'm joe rogan
talking about he believes that bands
shouldn't be forever
so who's to say that you know there
wouldn't be a root back
on these things but i do know that the
decision
was probably made
carefully reluctantly i think
i think it's the right decision i think
is the right decision and i think the
timing of it was probably right
i i would be you know it felt
it felt at the moment it took place
it felt like the intensity of dialogue
and the toxicity of dialogue was
reaching such a stage
that you know six people already dead
it's just like
this could get this can escalate even
further and i have to say
since it's happened it does feel to me
like a bit of the stress in the room has
gone
someone said something uh about i think
president-elect biden said um the you
know a natural order of things you don't
think about your leaders
every day you kind of know they're there
you've got context that they
have an awareness but you know this
sense of peril where you're thinking
about your leader and what might happen
every day
just contributes to bad mental health
it's not a healthy place for us to live
in
so you know i would guess that there
would always be a route back
for people even if they've had a
permanent ban
jack said that but i i do think it was
the right decision
i i am i'm really not sure i think
i consider myself as someone that's on
the left i guess to some degree or maybe
left to center left but
um i it does make me feel a little bit
uncomfortable because you're right it
sets a bit of a presence for the future
in terms of how we deal with um
opinions we don't like things that might
be considered to be inciting violence
would you have done in this case
i think i think i would have um
suspended
his account um temporarily like the
facebook approach
yes i think that was i think that was
probably a better approach all things
considered
um i think because trump is a very
unique very powerful individual
i would have also had someone i'm not
sure if this happened but someone from
twitter
contact his team and really have a
dialogue about it and
lay out that we can't allow our platform
to be a place where we're like denying
the election results and
therefore inciting you know these kinds
of things and basically
do and i would have used this suspension
period i think to have that conversation
uh um but yeah but i think with the
removal is it sets a bit of a strange
presence
and i did wonder before this moment you
know social media is very left
it's a very it's a very like a liberal
place
i think if you were to just look at
social media you would think that
the labor party you're always going to
win typically as well because
you think i think so because i think
that's more a reflection of who you
follow because
you know i definitely think there's
plenty of pockets of people who
are huge brexit supporters who clearly i
mean the numbers say that there's more
of them
yeah but it's just i think the brexit
and the conservative
narrative is less akin to like the
virtue signaling that you're rewarded
for on social media
so if i say uh child a lunch boxes for
all
right everyone's eager but if i was to i
i would prob i might even lose my job or
be canceled or be criticized if i said
oh no we don't need to fun give as much
money to the nhs or something
so just seems like the liberal the sort
of left talking points are a little bit
more
acceptable on social media and the right
ones might
make you lose your job or get you
cancelled or you know what i mean i
think it's about tonality rather than
uh perspective i mean look you know
absolutely it's not going to play well
if you're in the market for likes to say
that i think we need a tighter fiscal
policy
and you know and less benefits for
people he's going to play
differently i wouldn't necessarily agree
that the platforms have
a specific bias though i think you know
of course it's my echo chamber
yeah generally you know i've witnessed
plenty of strong
opinion on both sides likely as it was
my job to try and
ensure there was a a degree of good
conversation in those things
and i i've probably not seen that
because i've only seen my own little
echo chamber and i'm young i'm
you know i'm surrounded by very left
uh people in my organization and stuff
so i probably surrounded myself with
that narrative a bit more
but i just i've always felt that um
where does social media go from here i
mean it's
it feels like it's a really pivotal
moment we've got this big case with
facebook at the moment in the us where
they're trying to you know considering
breaking up facebook and
we've got trump being banned from
twitter we've got parlor being pulled
from the app store and amazon web
services
um it feels like we're in a bit of a i
don't know maybe we've always been
in this constant debate of what social
media is and where the lines are but
what what are some of the big changes
you see coming to look i think
it's pretty clear that regulations
coming in some in some
capacity uh i think to be honest i think
most of the big organizations would
welcome it when it comes to choosing to
de-platform people whether they're the
president or whether they're
troublemakers
having some rules that are agreed by an
independent
authority would be welcome for most of
those platforms i think
you know it's really uncomfortable when
organizations are losing sleep
being on the inside is really
uncomfortable when you're losing sleep
about
should we be doing this can we be doing
this how do we account for doing this
uh jack daughter did a series of tweets
a couple of nights ago
trying to he's formidable i think
trying to demystify how decisions are
made so no win almost everyone who reads
it will be critical of it
but you know he's trying to say look
this is how we reach that decision
um i think there'll be degree of
regulation i think that's probably a
good thing
i suspect some of the big groups will be
broken up
and you know facebook and google i think
will probably be broken up and the
question will be
whether they are willing to embrace that
and do it
and all of the shareholders and all of
the users and all the people who work
there benefit
or if they resist it and you know the
lessons of microsoft
bill gates and steve balmer will say we
lost 10 years of our company
because we spent 10 years resisting
uh regulation resisting control had they
just
given up to that they'd probably
microsoft's in a good place again i
think biggest company in the world again
but you know they
uh they would have been in a better
place to to avoid those things so
um i think regulations probably coming i
think it's probably a good thing
do you think they're gonna break up
facebook yeah you think they will yeah
in the next five years
really so you think they'll force
facebook to sell
whatsapp or instagram or something yeah
or both yeah or both yeah really
almost certainly i would guess youtube
will be sold from google as well
really yeah blimey that's crazy
better go somewhere is it better for a
consumer
so number one if you own any of those
shares every time that these breakups
uh the all of the value of the firms is
worth more than the constituent parts
so from shareholder point of view it's a
really good idea
to pick the right moment but break
yourself up and
um and it's good from a consumer point
of
view
i often sit there big youtube consumer
if you're a youtube consumer you said go
going hang on this used to be like the
big daddy of video
they've missed tick tock they've missed
twitch
they've missed like all of these big
opportunities that youtube was
right in the box seat for they've missed
all of them why because big firms
generally are slow and don't innovate
and so it's better for everyone if
you've got people
experimenting doing new things and you
know if you've got a layer of regulation
over the top of that
saying these degrees of norms of
behavior that you expect
it's it's much better for everyone and
it's really exciting i think
in the case of facebook mark mark would
respond to that and say we've got 10
years or
15 years whatever it is now of
experience moderating
terrorist content and you know really
you know horrific types of content we've
built
ai systems which are the best in the
world and we're removing you know we're
spotting 90
of posts before they're reported and
this has taken us you know
decades and billions of dollars of
investment to get to this point if you
take instagram and put it in the hands
of an i don't know an adobe
they don't have that experience they
don't have that um data
that they don't have the ai systems and
so it's not going to help
for um missing misinformation and it's a
misdirection though isn't it i mean
that specifically if someone is saying
we have learned we've developed
machine learning that can do these
things that sounds like a marketable
product
that sounds like something that
shouldn't be the point of difference
that shouldn't be your differentiator
that you've got better capacity to deal
with those things but rather that should
be something that
some entrepreneur avails to other firms
and i think you know sometimes we can
get locked into an idea of thinking
oh the narrative that we're being given
is the right one here
but rather more than thinking actually
if someone could put a layer of safety
over the internet
that used that machine learning to spot
things that were really heinous that
that used that learning to make sure
that no one had a bad experience
wow pinterest could use that linkedin
could use that
tic toc could use that it should be
something that everyone could plug
into their products and then you
immediately start saying wow
there could be gaps in the market for
new products here maybe there's a
version of twitter that's mega safe
maybe there's a version of instagram
that just has a different aspect to it
so you know my view would be absolutely
we've learned
these things but the notion that somehow
that safety of experience should be a
proprietary benefit
rather than something that is afforded
to everyone
is just i think a a a
bit of deception and a bit of
misdirection the other talking point
mark zuckerberg would rebuttal you
basically
because i've looked at his arguments for
not breaking up facebook he says well
what have we got a monopoly in
we're not as big as imessage in
messaging we're not as big as this
platform
for uh he and he rattles through the
platforms and says what what are we
bigger what are we
the monopoly on and um he says there's
tons of competition we've got tick tock
our heels pinterest
twitter you know uh google you know
these platforms so he says you know
where is the monopoly here
um and i have found that kind of
compelling i know again it's a bit of a
misdirection but
i i can't tell you what he's the what
what
facebook have the monopoly on
yeah well firstly monopolies don't have
to be more than 70
i think you know i think by the rules
for monopoly in the uk it's like more
than 20 30 percent of a market so
you know so so to be monopolistic you
don't have to be dominant
but you know when you've got three of
the top five apps
you start questioning whether there is a
degree of undue influence look i've got
no dog in the fight
um my view personally is that
i i suspect these firms will be broken
up and the question then becomes
do you serve your employees better
do you serve the people who use your
apps better do you serve
the the state of society better
by just going with that and saying let's
do it but let's do it
joyfully get on with it and i suspect
personally i think you know some of
these organizations are going to be
presented with
the the challenge some of them will go
okay i'll break
we'll break ourselves up and others will
say actually we're going to
uh we're going to position with this and
just the less than microsoft is
you lose 10 years of your life by
resisting talk a lot about the joy of
work
we've talked a lot about you know your
past experiences at youtube and twitter
what is next for you when you're
thinking about what's going to give you
joy
from work in the future what are you
thinking about um i'm writing a book
about resilience
uh are you able to tell us the title
yeah i mean it's the title is
a big ongoing discussion okay i'm not at
that stage um
which is just about all about the things
we've talked about how resilience is
actually a collective thing rather than
an individual thing
um i've really enjoyed sort of doing
things like that
i i i'm doing a couple of things on
climate change so i worked with an
organization last year
yeah yeah so i'm working with alcohol's
climate reality now
but um i did something with an
organization last year that's trying to
reduce our plastic
footprint and you know so so
there's a few things like that and i
really enjoy those things because they
i think they're non-linear i think you
know what success looks like is really
hard to judge
and it's all about trying to achieve
things so i did something
through october where i presented into
about 100
70 different companies i presented
climate change into 70 different
organizations
and you know connections have started
from that so the
al gore's climate reality is al gore did
that film an inconvenient truth about 15
years ago probably short in school
my dad made me watch it right sat me
down and said to my brothers and sisters
you got to watch this
and he's turned he's work on that into
an organization
and it used to be he had to pay 7 000 to
go and be trained in las vegas
now he's in the era of zoom he said
anyone could be trained on it for free
really so i trained the only commitment
you have to do is you have to commit to
spread the word
so hence i did about you know all these
presentations getting out and
and spreading the word um and that's
really energizing sort of
because i think a lot of us feel a
certain way towards climate but
feel powerless about what can we do so
uh i've done a bit of that
hopefully i'll i'm i've got a few more
things coming along on that so
will you ever get back into the world of
social networking i i really want to
avoid
doing that so that's why i'm working
hard on
podcast and writing because if i can pay
the bills doing that
you know full-time jobs are really
demanding
and you know my my social media
consumptions remains
i'm a huge user of twitter i'm a huge
user of tick tock
and uh so my social media consumption is
still there i just don't want to
i just don't want to work in those
organizations again why
just you know they're really exhausting
you know like you work really hard i had
so much fun working at twitter and
youtube before
but you know you do long days especially
working with california
up in the morning and you you're working
late at night so
i don't want to really go and work in a
big company again
i'm going to conclude this podcast by
just asking you you know
for you and from everything you know
about the joy of work and what makes
work joyful and fulfilling
if you had to just focus on one thing
that was the most important factor for
you
um in work what would that be um
there's a 70 year long study out of uh
yale university looking at what
the the secret of longevity and
happiness is and the secret of it
studied
these guys for like the whole of their
lives and the secret of longevity and
happiness
is love and friendship and i think
work is far closer to that than we might
imagine when we feel a connection with
the people we work with
it makes everything worthwhile and i
think
hidden in all the chat about
productivity and strategy
and and you know market fear and usps
we lose the fact that when we feel most
motivated by work
it's when we feel like we're doing it
with other people
and so that's it for me i used to a
great day at work was when i laughed
12 times and you know and it was almost
it felt trivial to mention that it felt
like
oh why do you love your job to mention
that i just love these people i love
being around these people i'm energized
by these people
feels really embarrassing to admit but i
think that's the secret of it when we
feel part of something our jobs can feel
defining that can feel part of our
identity bruce thank you
um that loops perfectly round to the
start of the podcast in my expression
that i think remote work as hell so
but also it's uh it's something that
yeah i've come to learn over the last
nine months i'm sure a lot of other
people have
um thank you so much for all the work
you've done on work generally because i
think
it's a conversation not a lot of people
are having or breaking through with
and some of the ideas you deliver in
your book and just generally in your
content across
youtube and your social channels
linkedin your articles on there
i think really are helping to dismantle
a conventional and sometimes toxic
framework for how work has to be so on
behalf of someone that works and has
teams i want to thank you for that
because it's been um it's a value that
the world needs but also thank you for
the conversation today
thank you it's an absolute pleasure
thank you
[Music]
oh
you